So let's talk about some problems
of centralized main memory and
why we may want to do something else.
As we have seen in the previous quiz,
memory size is a problem.
We need a large memory, and
because it's all one big memory,
that one memory will be slow and,
because of its large size, relatively
far away from all of the cores.
We will also have the problem
of memory bandwidth.
Because misses from all
cores go to the one memory.
So the requests from all of
the cores create contention for
memory bandwidth because our big, slow
memory will have a limited bandwidth.
And what that does is it prevents,
really, additional cores from
benefiting our performance.
Because all of the accesses
are really serializing
in the queue waiting for memory.
So if we add more cores,
that just makes every core's accesses
even slower because they have
to wait for memory even longer.
So we don't really get
a performance advantage.
So centralized main memory because
of this problems works well only for
relatively small machines, with
something like 2, 4, 8, maybe 16 cores.
Beyond this, we saturate
the memory bandwidth and also
our memory needs to know the too big and
too slow if we keep it centralized.